and normally labor day weekend it's a
huge weekend here in las vegas
the lbcva says it brought in about 400
million dollars just last year
but this year it's a lot different and
officials are urging caution
hector mejia live now with the efforts
to avoid a spike in cases hi hector
hillary alex good morning and this will
not be a regular labor day weekend here
on the las vegas strip or anywhere else
and experts right now are saying
now is not the time to let your guard
down and here's why as the weekend
approaches
experts are warning about a possible
repeat of fourth of july weekend
they say it was right around that
weekend when states across the usa
surge in new coronavirus cases the
warning they're warning everyone to
remain
vigilant during this pandemic that means
wear a mask
social distance avoid large crowds and
if you can
keep gatherings outside we don't want to
see a repeat
of the surges that we have seen
following other holiday weekends
we don't want to see a surge under any
circumstances but particularly as we go
on the other side of labor day and
enter into the fall we want to go into
that with a running start in the right
direction
here in nevada according to governor
steve sisolak case numbers for the
coronavirus are decreasing and so is our
seven day average on positivity rate
however
he said nevada is one of only 11 states
in the entire country
that still has a positivity rate above
10 percent and the governor said
that how we handle this weekend will
have an impact on how we recover from
this
economically